okay jazz do you want to be an episode
of Tamara's never seen but that'd be
phenomenal what are we watching Big
Trouble in Little China oh my god you
never took me - hi guys my name is
Tamara chambers and a dog walker and
this is terras ever seen
and today we're watching Big Trouble in
Little China yes next time I have not
seen this everyone's like but this is
one of the movies I haven't seen um so I
know nothing about it not a thing I know
the true screws on poster that is it
it's a beautiful poster I don't know a
damn thing outside of it no I don't know
where takes place I don't know who's in
it I don't know anything
nope it's like I'm assuming it's a
comedy like an adventure comedy but I
don't could be very dramatic mm-hmm well
I'm very excited oh no I thought it was
gonna be I have a feeling it might be
like that but not like the whole way
through this is like manic fury rolling
once it starts it just doesn't stop I
found that it was gonna be like action
II and funny like that but there were so
many elements that I was like what the
fault was that
I don't know it gonna be like monsters
coming out I'm grabbing my balls like
flawless back to keep going under like
magic it's even never explained or like
when they do explain it it's like look I
don't know we're just fighting this shit
what's happening cool let me finish it
we don't even know I oh it was yeah okay
tell me so many questions no big
concerns I loved it
first of all I would like to address
Kurt Russell breath
this is the biggest goddamn whiter
everything like you cuz they like what's
going on hey you shut up give me a knife
it's like you've done way with just a
whiny little pissant that
yes I love him like I should hate this
guy like if I kind of do but it's like I
love that I hate him yes yes yes yes boy
he's such a jerk but I want to watch you
in every movie yeah like all I think of
is ash from Evil Dead movie that
apparently from what I heard cuz they
watched each other stuff so I guess like
you know maybe Kurt Russell took a
little bit from Bruce Campbell and that
brick Campbell took a little bit from
Kurt Russell in this movie because like
yeah Kurt Russell like on in this movie
cam looks like he's imitating Evil Dead
2 but then like an army of Darkness was
like Bruce Campbell was imitating that
that's what my brother was saying and
I'm just like yeah sounds right because
I know they knew each other so yeah it's
a good vision he didn't say that to like
halfway through and then I was like oh
my god yeah that's exactly what's
happening here and more movies need
Bruce Campbell heroes I mean they're
both like they're they're badass but
they're incompetently stupid
yeah and they always do the wrong thing
at the time and he has no idea what's
going on and he's like keeps asking like
what is what is this what's going on
pissed off as possible yeah like you
look at me seeing this incredible vision
I wanted that he goes an elevator that's
what it goes down wait is that an
elevator not yelling
I wrote down um she's this hero he's the
white person hero where white people
shouldn't be the story of America they
travel a little China exactly what this
whole movie is this is Kurt Russell like
and always thought his situation
all he does is complain about how he
does understand foreign stuff so yeah it
is very very polite in America I love it
me point that out in a great way like
the end where he like does he like
shoots the ceiling and it gets knocked
out by the rubble that he's out for like
ever battle yeah yeah I feel this whole
movie like it's stuff I would hate you
know the movies like everything about
the hero is a complainer the plotted
cliched it moves too fast there's too
much stories and not enough story is all
stuff I love about this film and like
and I I can't explain why
I don't know why it is somehow it works
in this movie and I just love it and she
is magical like morphing of this
hilarious action magic doesn't make any
sense
creatures are what the father what is it
eyeball blob right here
I was either like clapping or just like
what so the ones that just got me the
most out of nowhere is like if they're
crawling through like this I don't of
cave and there's like things bubbling
and stuff and they look at something
down that makes it centers like to see
that it's like like what like
something's breathing underwater so
where everybody's looking down their
behinds of the same obstacles we're all
forgotten what was that if the so so
keep going and it's like I know if I
know what that well those in the water
where that thing come from and it's to
you doing the practical in fact that
just comes out of nowhere and you don't
see that many monsters in this is like
maybe three and they're all completely
different so you don't know what this
it's like you is only one of each or is
this like an ancient like Chinese
lobster so there's Mary's okay my
favorite part was they killed the main
bad guy what's the actor's name James
hung simple um so they kill him and then
they're finding like his
second-in-command they kill him or no
did they kill him no yeah no like you
see that is masters dead even locals
like it decide he just expanded blue
could we hear what Wyatt no you couldn't
predict any of it I mean like when it
happens it's like you know like in a
story wise is like okay I'll it's just
these tough guys going to save the women
from an evil monster you know they
whatever but it's like the way to happen
even just coming across monsters okay
we've all seen monsters the peace
monsters are just so out of nowhere and
so weird there's like a floating head
with a bunch of eyeballs even as an
eyeball in its mouth and it's like you
could have cut that top of this movie
carpet cut out
100% totally not needed but that's part
of what makes it amazing in place like
the Big Lebowski just why would they
have half of it I don't yeah I'm okay so
I really like to be acting I really like
the the lead spunky I didn't get any
made the bleep funky woman she was great
but there was the other one she didn't
have one line I don't think like yeah
you got Kim Cattrall you have the
reporter and I'll bring any of the other
women at any height but to be fair
there's like a million people in this
movie um and yet that's the thing we can
control to like every single time like
when Kurt Russell is on screen either I
can play about that I hate that she
always comes out she's like we got to do
something we have to do this and we have
to do this thing everything over there
very expensive thing to hassle blah blah
and they're just both on these one notes
their own separate notes but they are
just they never stop and they're just
constantly doing it and so much fun and
so much energy
yeah oh I didn't bring up that hold on
you see right there does I'll say right
here doing I didn't wear this now I
didn't Jim I was like you guys doing
that movie you guys hear this honey uh
sure just as Jax like that I all love
his show the porkchop Express because
he's droning on my goodness how John
Wayne or whatever I listen to me I'm
like who is listening to this guy cool
other truck drivers I have no sir I feel
like shit bring up the channel so mad Oh
turn it off it's kind of like podcast
before there were podcasts I think yes
structures truckers had their own
podcast for years we just didn't listen
to it what was amazing
I cry it's like there's so much to talk
about but it's like such a bore and then
happen so fast I'm like it just hits you
I mean it's like it's kind of still
hitting me and I just watched it yeah
like it just went by so fast and I came
to comprehend how long the movie was
avails an hour and a half or two hours
or or what I I can't I can't click it I
have no comprehension in the best way
what I just wish that focus on you were
like I was like what's going on you're
like the last five minutes have been a
mystery
yeah I think I'm like the two women are
like given the sores and they're flying
up and then they touch the lightbulb and
I just thought how many green eye women
does it take the change of life all is
well I can figure oh I was wanting to
Jesse when you know Russell tried
throwing the knife completely misses and
the bad guy get names like on so nice
night goodbye and you think either
somebody's going to come out and grab it
or save them because when the bad guy
says goodbye you know it's not going to
go as he wants but something hot some
sort of twist is going to stop him you
know from killing the hero and here it's
just like no major traffic right back it
was so unexpected but that kind of
unexpectedness just like you said I mean
if I was in the theater I'd be like ah I
got you applauding every second yeah
yeah and the present practical effects
are so good like with the knife in his
head was hilarious and awesome well okay
I didn't understand is why he wearing
them was Benny no you're right to
medievalist I didn't understand why he
was trying so hard to do the ritual
during that big fight the ritual makes
him human again why didn't he just wait
until his guys took down the other the
people going against him and then become
human because then he wouldn't have died
I'm impressed you got even that far yeah
if you were to say what's the bad guys
planned in this I'd be like ah
something about green eye woman make
them the mortal makes him human makes
him live longer makes him that old I
don't know he sounds hilarious when he's
in the wheelchair i mean ii 2,000 years
to find this woman and then in like two
seconds later he's like ah another
green-eyed woman like what are the odds
and what what even I mean there has to
be I mean especially if he can just
choose an American one is Isis or just
has to be the other green eyed women I
credibly I mean God all in this top of
my head I can't think of anybody I mean
I don't usually pay that much attention
you would think it would be easier than
2,000 years yeah like something would
show up through contacts
couch pages pop oh yeah yeah I don't
know yeah lots of weird plot holes that
were hilarious and didn't matter
like it was like flying with me this
movie I'm I'm kicking myself I didn't
see this would be not only because it's
so great but I would have loved this as
a kid I think I probably would have been
like five years old when this came out
if I saw this movie I was in my ninja
turtle phase it was 86 I think or was it
later
yes I would have been about five years
old and I don't have midget rows came
out yeah but it's like I will loved it
this is just my stuff that I love these
weird little ninja weapons and the
shooting the lightning it just non-stop
so I mean I'm just one of those I'm like
how did I not grow up with this
definitely always say four cameras never
seen you like God boonies might have
seen that as a kid oh my god this was
all I think I enjoyed more as an adult
when I would have as a kid I think I my
mom let me watch it I also think that
the plot holes would have just I just
wouldn't been able to keep up I was just
feel like I don't I don't know what's
happening also scary mobster stuff if I
was as a teenager I don't know what I
would think I think I would still like
it might probably on the same boat idea
but the plot all don't make sense it
Kurt Russell's kind of a juror that is
like I wouldn't catch on vet the point
when I saw dark man I didn't catch on it
was meant to be funny you know I think
it's kind of the same thing where it's
only if I saw in the sound oh if I would
catch on it's like no no this is meant
that's the fun of it yeah so much of it
doesn't make any second darkness my
favorite movie is it really nothing I'll
guess that you must not see Matt come on
don't get me wrong but yeah it's
definitely Waldo's oh this is this is
meant to be stupid okay you know yeah
yeah for sure um yeah that was a blast
I I loved it I loved it I know why I can
see why it's a lot of people like
favorite movies and stuff it's just fun
show plan okay question for you not
about this movie okay do you think that
I should watch Beetlejuice next or never
any story that that's tough um never
ending story is a better movie but
beetlejuice you'll definitely get more
material how butyl deuce is the most
similar to Big Trouble in Little China
like it's not quite as fast but it
definitely is crazy and so much is not
explained and that's part of the fun of
it
okay and then second thing we have to do
a hair flip oh well that's gonna be a
little tricky with mine I don't have
much love you oh you can do a beard flip
oh I like that okay
yes you're welcome lovely alright well
um thank you so much for being I hear
them say for having me thank you chuck
carpenter for making a freaking awesome
alive we release it I'll go see
[Music]